[Applause]
how are you what a great audience they
are so fun I love them yes yeah thank
you it's the holiday so everybody is
happier I yes I like your fair how are
you I'm well yeah last time it was we
were over video screen we didn't get to
meet in person this my first time in
studio it's nice to be back in the real
world are you are you like ready for
Christmas I'm not totally prepared this
year I mean Christmas is my time I I get
into it at Christmas you know uh however
our kids are teenagers now and they kind
of staged an intervention with me this
year because I go a little crazy and
lots of Amazon boxes start showing up on
the porch I'm a Prime member yes there
you go and they were like listen we want
three things this year and we want time
with you and I was like okay be the
adults in the room they said time with
you I mean that's what my parent I
wanted to hear that's what I filtered
yeah I also found this out about you
because I love roock Hudson um I was
obsessed with him whenever I was in
junior high when I first started
watching those films like d day and
everything but you you recently did a
tribute right I did I did um are you a
fan I'm a big fan of rock um have been
since I was a kid you know that's sexy
man what yeah I mean there will never be
anyone as handsome as rock oh my God and
his smile stop it yeah I love your song
Rock Hudson I know I have I know I think
people were
confused by my me titling it that but it
was more because you think your life is
a movie and he's my favorite like people
love car Grant you know whatever you
have your person he's mine I don't care
that he didn't like
women I know I know you I would love him
enough for both of
us but it was so great to have someone
like that in the Zeitgeist as a career
person to see somebody out there who was
succeeding and out there in the
Limelight even if he wasn't totally open
at the time because it wasn't really
safe to do so absolutely um to see him
out there was so inspirational for me
and I think he's a great actor and a
wonderful human so yeah I mean
especially growing growing up in Texas
that probably was not easy no I was kind
of a fredet lights kind of town it's
it's grown since I left was that too
yeah so uh great people but I definitely
when I was in high school I had to like
just figure out a way to survive and
kind of get to a place where it felt
safe to be my most authentic self yeah
that's just that was just my experience
yeah I kind of survived High School too
though I think we for different reasons
felt life and death for all of us but
you know how people are like oh I would
go back and do like certain years never
I would never and I had a fine
experience but no no that that's hard
let's let's talk about fellow Travelers
though there's some similar issues in
there yeah yeah it is I mean my my
character can certainly relate it's a a
multi-decade love story that starts at
the height of the lavender scare and
goes in the 50s and goes all the way
through the 80s and we follow this group
of people over the course of four
decades and uh you know it's it's also a
political thriller that's based on real
events in our history I love that that
element too I love when people do that
they tie in historical things and it
kind of teaches you at the same time
like it certainly educated me I had kind
of a passing understanding of what the
lavender scare was but it was it was a
dark moment in our history where
basically uh Roy con and um Senator
McCarthy convinced Eisenhower to push
forth a bill that um an executive
measure that let them basically fire any
queer people from government uh and
expected 10,000 people lost their jobs
and a lot of folks committed suicide
people got on board with it like you
know what I'm saying like looking like
I'm it's like certain things in history
I'm like how did that happen like how
did enough people go this is fine I
think it's important to look back at
times when our fears got the better of
us you know so that we can not make
those mistakes going forward yeah yeah
yeah I think we still need progress yeah
well we need also a commercial break um
mat's new show is called fellow
Travelers it's on Showtime and look for
him in Maestro as well it's in theaters
and on Netflix starting December
[Music]
[Applause]
20th thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home